it was up guidance Marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with YouTube tips
episode number 5 and today I'm gonna be
talking about pancakes YouTube is kind
of like pancakes bear with me here I
have a good example I think this will
actually help you guys out so the other
day I went to go get breakfast and I
went to get breakfast on campus and I
went up in the cafeteria running kind of
late but I decided to go back by the
grill and by the grill there was kind of
a long line but there's this guy he's
behind the grill a huge girl and he's
just making all these breakfast food
she's just whipping up pancakes he's got
some sandwiches going on over here this
guy is big maybe ten people in line in
front of me and one guy in line up front
he says he says you know what do you
want and the guy says well let me get
this sandwich says all right those
wrongs grill
all right next guy what do you want okay
says this rosalyn grill and he's putting
all these things together on the grill
at the same time Denny's he's finishing
him up so he says here's your sandwich
here's a pancakes here's your waffles
here's whatever and so I I got up and I
ordered pancakes and two minutes later
my pancakes for done alright yes it was
pretty good so I brought him back to my
table and they were terrible they were
terrible pancakes they weren't really
well cooked at all basically the point
is this if you take YouTube the same way
that you take making food if you were
that guy behind the grill I would rather
have the audience or the consumers
waiting for great content rather than
just pumping out half-baked content all
the time if you're you know if you make
great content you really don't have to
worry about how fast you're making it
because you can be confident that it's
gonna make some people happier it's
gonna satisfy your goal so if you're
behind the grill if you find yourself
behind the girl cooking five things at
once and just throwing them all out
there and you don't really have any
personal connection to it you just kind
of make it
that's probably not the way you want to
take your approach to YouTube if you
find yourself behind the grill with just
one project you're working on and you
really make sure that project is done
well and the first thing you hand it to
the people who you give it out to are
really happy with it then you can have a
really successful YouTube channel and
maybe you can open up your own pancake
store someday yeah so that's basically
it thanks for watching this YouTube
video just a quick video also quick note
I have some really nice reviews coming
out for you guys so make sure you give
this video a like it really does help
out and I'll talk to you guys in the
next video thanks for watching peace
[Music]